[Music]
you seem to be fearless
but what's it like for you when you
actually see
a celebrity in person do you i think
first of all i get excited so i think
people that say it's not exciting to see
famous people are full of it i i still
get excited to see famous people all the
time but do you ever get worried that
they're going to be mad at you for
something all the time all the time i
live in fear when i run into people
especially from my act it's very
uncomfortable for them right
but i was i was at a restaurant last
week and um i
it was there are actually quite a few
celebrities there and like kris jenner
was there and i make fun of her family
and that's she's the mother of a lot of
dirty horse called the kardashians
and she was there
and uh i saw denzel washington who's of
course a big a-list star and i just kind
of gawked at him and looked at him and
stuff but i will tell you as much as
he's excited to see celebrities when
charlie sheen rolled in oh he came to
the restaurant yes oh i actually got
physically frightened and it takes a lot
to scare me as you know
i um i like when i actually thought the
words in my head like don't see me don't
see me don't see me because i didn't
know if you would like spit a tooth at
me i i didn't know if he was going to be
winning i am
you know i and it's usually i love to
mix it up with a celebrity or take a
picture or meet somebody but it's kind
of like um i've i've you know performed
overseas and whenever i go to like iraq
or whatever i get to visit like the
canine division and you have those dogs
that are trained and they're super scary
but one of the trainers said that a dog
will be scared of someone truly crazy
and they said that's the only thing that
could kind of freak out a dog and when i
saw charlie sheen i felt like a watchdog
and i kind of like was shaking a little
bit like
but i i
i knew i could not protect the people
around me like a good canine because
charlie sheen scared the hell out of you
so yeah so he's yeah did he behave
himself did you have an encounter with
him behave he rolled up to the bar with
his homies i guess he's not a
spokesperson for the 12-step program
right um because you know when i saw him
go to the bar in particular i thought
this can't end well right and then i
looked at denzel washington who oddly
was in a track suit so i thought run
denzel run um for your safety run but he
is charlie sheen i would say is one of
the very few celebrities that i would
see and slightly fear right right other
than that it's go time i'll make an
astroglide joke about just about anybody